that men are weaker in 2022
100 yes
in what way though I think there's
something still playing blessing oh
there's traffic okay
from from what I think
I'm going to compare the men I see now
to what my dad was hmm now my dad took
it overboard he was he was over like
masculine over
a misogynist if that's the word
um
whereas now
I'll talk about the physical side but
this is not the important side I'm just
saying
like now I'm a dancer I've been a dancer
for a few years
now I see dancers
putting on uh like makeup and just none
of it nothing wrong with that absolutely
nothing wrong with that but it's it's a
feminine trait right so it it also comes
into like the personality side where
the men I see now are not as tough as
probably my dad was he was he was he was
proper like
I run the house I don't cook The Woman
Cooks
um this is my role this is the woman's
role whereas now it's all it's all very
mixed
um so I'm just curious why is that
misogynist
you said misogynistic what why is what
like your dad like why why do you use
that word uh because he was he was he
was um he never cooked a meal in his
house not when he was with my mom or
with my stepmom
he would say that certain things are for
her to do and not for him to do anything
that was to do with like the cars and
fixing or DIY he would do it
[Music]
he's fixing everything yeah he would do
all the like the hard labor stuff
whereas she was talking about all the um
this is good for women and I would think
that is where exactly I think men are
not many more they don't do they don't
do that yeah I don't do that anymore
yeah they'll look at me and tell me what
do you bring to the table ask them can
you fix anything like do you know how to
fix anything can he fix a toilet can he
fix the car can you change your tire do
you have to do that must man don't know
how to do that I I like this I like
those trains I like those traits too I
like sticking to part of it and I feel
like you can still be a feminist and
have no you can still be a feminist and
have traditional roles yeah and have at
home the problem is like you guys aren't
young virgins
so you that's like demanding traditional
outcomes when you're not traditional
women
like if you're a traditional woman you'd
be a young virgin
like I don't understand yeah yeah like
like okay so you're you're describing
things you're saying to the men like
you're not traditional men and I I agree
but we're not traditional women we're
not 22 you're 21 year old virgins they
value Purity in youth the average age of
first marriage in the UK is 31. that
that's not Pure or youthful how many
bodies you got by 31. oh okay loads yeah
if you look at your mom and dads
but if you look at your mom and dad how
many partners did they have before they
got this got together
exactly but I just think I don't think
that and we're all we're overweight too
that's the other thing yeah I don't
think many of them are getting weak I
don't think men are getting weaker I
just think that Society wants them what
Society wants us to believe it
and because nowadays everything's too
instant like you were saying about oh
men fix the car men do this men do that
nowadays your car breaks down they make
a phone call gets fixed yeah I mean we
as women we can we can do that you know
there are some women like I can fix my
car because I can I can put a light bulb
up I can I can I've got a table from
like a certificate in car maintenance so
but I'm not doing it I do the pink jobs
and he does but you know what I say I I
still like obviously we are not going to
be virgins at this age of course not but
um I I do like the fact that my partner
when something breaks in the house I
love seeing him take take out his tools
and doing that yeah and then oh baby let
me make your sandwich while you do that
I like that I still like that obviously
it's not going to be I'm not I'm not the
30 year old virgin hell no but no and
and I I agree with you like I think it's
attractive but it's just like we're
asking for traditional outcomes but
we're not traditional women oh no not at
all we're not also I wouldn't have to
point out like the fact that I think
Paul pointed out as well that you use
the word misogyny which is a negative
word and I think what you explained was
your dad just having roles in the house
and relationship and I think I think
that's a pertinent thing to notice that
that that misogyny is like a disdain for
women yeah don't forget there's one of
those um key words the one there was new
words that they use I'm writing them
down I'll be writing them down in a
minute all this all these words keep on
coming out and everybody's using this
I agree when you say the word misogyny
is not it's not good but the reason why
I say it is because he went he went
overboard like one time we were in a
restaurant I went I went to Karama back
on holiday and he was like oh let's go
have a meal in a restaurant
and um and we were at the restaurant and
the way the way he was treating the way
it was like bring me this and why are
you not bringing me this and I was like
because he to to him he was he was the
alpha male wherever he was or wherever
he went and because he had businesses
and and good status or whatever he he
carried himself like that and
that's why I say he was so misogynistic
that I don't agree with it
he might just think to himself do you
know what I'm paying for a service and I
want to service right exactly yeah but
he did it in the like the wrong way and
he wasn't I mean he could be he could be
rude yeah like what is what does
misogynist affect you
okay my understanding is some uh
masculine in its overbearing masculine
no that that's what she actually thinks
though like I think people people modern
feminists that's what they actually
think they think misogyny is just being
a man it's masculinity but they think
that's the problem
um but it's at this damn woman so
misogyny is kind of like judging someone
purely based on their gender and kind of
an oppressive way I think like saying
things like you you can't it's the
hatred of women yeah but the action of
misogyny is is kind of like you can't
you can't have this job because you're a
woman you know XYZ that's how it you
know it shows itself it's not being rude
to a waiter or saying uh my wife she
cooks I pay for the bills that's not my
suggestions being you know a man who
believes in roles may be overbearing at
times but do you know I was just
thinking heard that sounds like a older
version of Andrew Tate
[Music]
he didn't have a big mouth like Tate
does but he was he was very in his
actions very that's the woman's role and
this is the man's role and there ain't
no in between and that's fair enough you
have a right to Define roles in your
relationship is consensual right if if I
say you have to do this and I do this
yeah but you know something about even
though she looks in it as if it's
something negative it worked for
appearance
and it works for them I noticed they
like aspects of it so no one complains
that like you know my dad was paying too
much of the bills and taking care of too
much stuff and really kind of protect us
too much it's only like random small
things then it's like misogyny and you
know the the thing is though oh do they
get the more they realize you know what
I I want to be like my parents but they
didn't have it so bad because the older
you get you're going to realize that
all of these roles that they had it
works it works and everybody's going
towards traditional and they're looking
at their parents and thinking no they
were too traditional but when you think
about it look at the longevity of your
parents relationship compared to the
longevity of the relationships now where
people decide they want to mix modern
with traditional which don't work so
Auntie would you describe yourself as a
modern woman no would you how would you
describe yourself because you've said
you're not traditional so I would say
I'm a traditionalist okay what does that
mean
that means that I'm not a virgin okay
and I'm having loads to say
and I still know my place but I would
say that if I was a virgin and I wasn't
the same person and I was married I'm
traditional I'm not I'm just an old bird
with Traditional Values how how do you
feel do you feel like over a certain age
modern women cannot have traditional
outcomes anymore it's a I had the same
conversation today with him indoors and
he just he it was just like they get to
this age
after being so modern
and they hit like the 35s and they think
you know what it's not working for me I
want to be traditional but then
the men that are out there that are one
traditional they don't want them because
the women are coming with this modern
values
trying to be traditional and you know
what you've got it or you ain't and you
can't mix the two you cannot mix the two
and women are out there they're too busy
trying to be modern but traditional but
no they're not even trying to be like a
normal woman with Traditional Values
they want to be modern and traditional
and they're gonna crash they're gonna
crash because the two can't work
together no matter what they say it
can't work I'm telling you it cannot
work you cannot be modern and
traditional at the same time modern is
all about look it up in the dictionary
modern is all about me me me me me
traditional is about us the village
raising everybody together so you can't
turn around and say oh I'm gonna be
modern it's all about me and I'm gonna
do traditional because it does not work
it's impossible you're fooling yourself
if you think you can be modern with
Traditional Values if I turned around
and I said oh I'm a traditionalist and
I'm gonna be modern I'm gonna go out I
want to get my nails done I'm gonna is
good I'm gonna get my hair done I want
to get makeup on my definitely you're
kidding yourself look at her old woman
do you know me or my undressed as lamb
they're not gonna accept it from a
traditional old person like me trying to
be modern so why do they think it's
gonna work that way around it don't yeah
how how do you feel like we can return
do you do you think there is any
returning to traditionalism for modern
women like is there any way they can do
it now forget about modern minimum I
want to start my grandchildren's age and
the children because there's no hope for
them the only thing I can do is all them
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible